one of the great restaurant areas that
are difficult to define you know you
will have a restaurant which happened
and everyone good and it's fantastic and
you'll go back and everything is great
from the food to the service to the from
the first moment you're there someone
say I want to do the same thing you open
another restaurant you go there and
everything is fine some somehow it
doesn't click exactly and you'll tell
people did you like it to say yeah it
was excellent and we all wear the same
service was very good too would you go
back p I probably will go back but there
is none of that excitement that you may
have in that first restaurant and
sometimes it's something which is very
very difficult to define exactly but
certainly the quality of the food the
quality of the service because you have
to be felt welcome without people being
condescending to you so those are what
make great restaurant yes there is never
a dish which is absolutely perfect you
know there it can earn some time you get
close enough that you're very satisfied
with yourself but again it has to do
with your own palate without any
question if you decide on the 10 best
restaurant in New York or the 10 best
restaurant in front and if I go to those
10 restaurant five maybe five six of
them I'm going to think are absolutely
extraordinary two or three of them I'm
going to sing they up quite good and a
couple of them i'm going to say i don't
understand why those people are three
star and what I'm saying there is that
you cannot escape yourself so the four
or five that I absolutely adore just
happened to coincide exactly with my
sense of taste with my sense of
aesthetic so it's purely a narcissistic
reflection if you want on my own taste
because that coincide with what I like
and the other one I'm not as familiar
with it so as I said to a certain extent
you can work with many from people but
you cannot escape yourself at some point
you are who you are and that will be
expressed in the food that's what I try
to tell the student at BU for example
that class of 10 12 student hands-on and
I do a class of two hours I say I'm
going to do the perfect meal for you
today a roast chicken a boiled potato
and a salad it has to be done exactly
the right way basting the right way the
salad has to be cleaned out the right
way so at the right temperature with the
right dressing the right oil with the
right amount right time for sure the
potato has to be done this way and so
forth fine so they do that they tested
then they go to the stove and do it now
they have two hours to duplicate my dish
my my Swedish and I always said don't
try to be original don't try to updo one
another to don't try to be different man
so what else because you are different
and whether you like on that for the
better or for the worse I am going to
have 10 different chicken a couple of
them practically perfect a couple cold a
couple undercooked a couple undercooked
occur but whatever they will be
different because you are different and
you cannot escape yourself so you don't
have to torture yourself to sign that
dish to make sure that people know
you've done it because it will be
different anyway Oh all these are with
the best restaurant around yeah there
are many other I mean as I say I
mentioned jean-georges in New York as
well as Danielle or or you know Kelly I
you know Thomas Keller it's
extraordinary are extraordinary
restaurant and there is only a few that
I mentioned there there is many many
many more in New York and all over the
top